ninja Cipher PK Tim the tapman Nick
Merks and courage JD have announced that
they are making their own Battle Royale
game and they're going to be doing it
inside fortnite but the best part is
that these five veterans want your
opinion to make it great I had some
conversations with Epic
we're like is this something we could
actually potentially do like we make our
own game inside of Unreal Engine
fortnite and they said absolutely
[Music]
thank you
okay so before we get into the video I'm
sure some of you are not subscribed and
I'm not trying to pressure anybody but
I'm just saying if you enjoy the content
we'd really appreciate knowing that you
are along for the ride cheers okay so a
couple weeks ago I dropped a video about
Unreal Engine for fortnite you can go
back and check it out if you want but
I'll get you up to speed here no worries
basically epic games made the Unreal
Engine one of the most popular game
engines in the world available to use to
build things in fortnite some of those
things don't look anything like fortnite
and players who build these things are
already getting paid out under this new
model where instead of Creator codes or
trying to get donations or something
epic just pays creators when people play
their maps you can already check out
uefn if you install fortnite there are
maps that are featured in a playlist or
whatever but eventually epic is hoping
to take all of the features from Unreal
Engine and make them available in
fortnite but calling these things Maps
isn't that helpful because because due
to uefn allowing you to build kind of
whatever you need they don't necessarily
look or play anything like fortnite and
to be clear project V is just the name
of the project it's not the name of the
game I mean I guess it could be but I
don't think it'll end up being that
announced on Friday the game will have
its own models world and lore and some
of the biggest brains in Battle Royale
will be helping to guide it we've all
played battles for a very long time and
on top of that we're all kind of right
now in our own Battle Royale Avenue if
you will right I'm still like Warzone
heavy
um NYX Apex heavy siphon Tyler obviously
pretty fortnite heavy and what we want
to try to do is build a battle royale
out ourselves with the knowledge we have
from playing Battle Royale for so long
even between these five massive
streamers by the way get the v in
Project V now there is a diversity of
experience for example Nick Merks
primarily an apex guy now and you can
often find him beefing with the CEO and
I mean honestly I got clipped and when I
got clipped I didn't hear it nor seated
so talking to your boys and maybe it
would have been different I'm just
saying Tim has taken to Warzone even
making cameos in promotional materials
let's go
let's go let's go you see what I did
there you got it right
ninja Cipher PK and courage have focused
more on fortnite over their careers
although obviously they've all bounced
around and played different games so why
is this so exciting well for one these
guys really do know Battle Royale I was
gonna add up all their play time I even
had someone helping me with it thanks
Nick but it was tricky because some of
them had moved platforms some of them
only stream on YouTube now Etc but once
I looked at Cypher PK and saw that
before this year he had almost 10 000
hours in fortnite I figured you guys
would just get the point with that these
guys live and breathe Battle Royale so I
feel that they understand two things
pretty well the first is Battle Royale
as a genre and maybe where it could go
from here the second of course is that
each of these five creators has a large
fan base and so they know how to manage
that too let's be honest though the
Battle Royale craze is going to turn six
years old this year and in that time we
really haven't seen a lot of innovation
incrementally sure things like the gulag
or being able to respawn your team more
generally is a welcome addition and one
that makes the game more fun to play
with friends of varying skill levels and
of course we've got stuff like Warzone
loadouts that helps to reduce RNG in
Loot and that is of course very good as
well these were big complaints that were
slowly addressed over time by developers
as people sort of started to realize
what they liked and didn't like about
the whole Battle Royale experience
people did try to create weirder battle
royale's but the ones that stuck around
well they have a few things in common
now this isn't the first time we've seen
a streamer step into the world of game
development not even close obviously
some high profile examples are doctor
disrespect who's making his own game as
well as nadeshot and 100 thieves who
have demoed some preliminary gameplay of
their product and honestly looks kind of
cool but to me this feels different a
lot different we all got to see the
Battle Royale genre emerge and convince
tensions form but I think these five
guys can take this thing to the next
level a spokesperson for project V told
me that Cipher PK Nick and others are
maturing past the Creator gig and
looking to explore roles as creative
Executives while no one is abandoning
this stream anytime soon experimenting
with Project B is exactly the
opportunity to do that by building a
complete Game these guys will operate a
legit gaming studio with an additional
dozen or so dedicated employees it's a
big bet but if they can mobilize their
120 million plus strong Collective
audience towards the game the economics
around user generated fortnite will
reimagine their careers and that's the
thing right by building the game in
fortnite they access that humongous
audience it's almost like fortnite is a
platform but it's a platform that's
available on basically any platform and
of course on top of fortnite's fan base
these five guys have massive fan bases
that I'm sure will be at least in
interested in the results of this game
but they might also be more invested
than that because project V is going to
give fans the ability to weigh in on the
decisions that the developers will be
making now In fairness we've heard this
one before Community feedback is
important to us as an easy thing to say
but can you actually pull it off can you
actually incorporate it do you want to
incorporate it I think though that these
people have more than enough fans who
are interested in seeing them succeed
that that won't be an issue plus this
isn't some web 3 rug pull right like if
they want to get paid by epic then the
project B developers have to make a game
that people actually play rather than I
don't know sign you up to a subscription
or sell you some crypto [__] coin or
something so I guess what I'm saying is
Nick Merk's courage JD Cypher PK ninja
and Tim the tatman want your opinion on
how to build the best Battle Royale
again from a project the spokesperson
community involvement will be absolutely
Paramount not only will it welcome
creative original contributions but also
provide a super valuable immediate
feedback loop that could avoid
development pitfalls example we don't
build stuff players don't want
specifically the team will operate a
dedicated Discord server produce regular
newsletters and host virtual Town Halls
that will provide for regular updates
and solicit feedback I was told they're
launching their Discord server soon and
you can go pre-register for that already
they're also hiring full-time roles
through Cypher PK's Oni Studios so if
you've got those kinds of skills maybe
you could get even more involved but
even if you don't have those skills you
could still have an impact on this game
and that's me on its own it's pretty
damn cool so is it gonna have building
is it gonna have a gulag is it going to
have pump shotguns we don't know we just
don't know yet but to steal a joke from
Tim's chat it probably won't have fall
damage right Appalachian State did you
[__] actually yeah
damn fall damage wait wait wait no no no
no no no no no no no no no
I'm honestly legit excited for this
thing like I thought that smaller
developers would be slowly getting you
know trying this thing out just to see
see if it's good you know see if they
can actually make money what it's like I
do hope it doesn't have building because
I'm a boomer but